lo que quiero hacer con esta fracción 8
décimos es transformarla en algo que
esté en centenas puedo poner una
interrogación o una estrella lo que sea
sobre 100 y lo que me interesa es
encontrar el valor que tomaría esta
estrella para que existiera esta
igualdad los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta
ahora para ayudarnos a comprender esto
tengo aquí unas imágenes una que
representa los ocho décimos y otra que
es el mismo entero pero dividido en cien
partes iguales en lugar de estar
dividido en diez y queremos ver cuántas
de estas cien partes iguales equivalen a
estos ocho decimos ocho de estas diez
partes de aquí
pensemos en este momento este entero
está dividido en diez secciones iguales
y hemos iluminado una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete y ocho este diagrama
representa esta fracción cómo podemos
hacer lo mismo con este otro diagrama
vamos a elegir la herramienta de color
el equivalente de un décimo en
centésimas es de 10 cuadritos el
equivalente de dos décimos son otros 10
cuadritos más cada que tengamos una
décima más agregaremos resaltaremos 10
cuadritos más vamos a ponerle aquí
1 entre 10 es igual a 10 entre 100
cada vez que lleno una décima
aquí tendré que resaltar diez de las
secciones de aquí 10 centésimos
si quiero resaltar ocho décimos serán 80
céntimos
ya llevamos 20 centésimas aquí van 30
centésimas 40 centésimas 50 centésimas
60 centésimas 70 centésimas y 80
centésimas
no tengo que resalte la misma cantidad
del entero que teníamos aquí que es
igual a éste otro entero cuantos
cuadritos ilumine resalte 80 cuadritos
de los 100 que tenía mientras que aquí
tengo resaltados 8 de 10 de mis
rectángulos iguales tenemos resaltada la
misma área en ambos enteros iguales así
que ocho décimos va a ser igual a 80
sobre 100 en este entero 8 de 10 son
iguales a 80 sobre 100
simplemente dividimos el entero en más
partes iguales
podemos verlo matemáticamente si
multiplicamos el denominador por 10 para
pasar de decimos a centésimos significa
que cada uno de estos ocho décimos
representa 10 veces más 8 por 10 es
igual a 80 de los 108 décimos es igual a
80 entre 100 en general cuando vamos a
reescribir una fracción sin cambiar su
valor siempre que multipliquemos
2 y el denominador por la misma cantidad
no cambiaremos el valor de la fracción
esto también se cumple si dividimos el
numerador y el denominador entre la
misma cantidad el valor de la fracción
no cambiará por eso si multiplicamos por
10 numerador y denominador llegamos a
este resultado